So it's pretty clear that this triangle
is half the area of this square.
But what about an example like this one?
We can show with just a couple of folds
and cuts that the area of this triangle
is a half the area of the rectangle
that shares the same base and height.
Okay,so I'm just going to fold along
these lines and cut where the lines are.
Okay, so now I have three triangles, and
we can see that they used to
make this nice rectangle.
But if I just flip some things around,
I can see that what I cut out is
exactly the same area as what's left.
So again, the area of
the triangle is half the area
of the rectangle that shares
the same base, length, and height.
So given what we just saw, what is a
good formula for the area of a triangle?
Here's a hint, the area of a rectangle
which we normally write as L times W,
is also base times height.
Please select one.